Rob here with a GS news update yogs
venture the game that spawned from the
YouTube channel Yogscast has been
cancelled due to lack of funds Yogscast
is one of YouTube's top channels it
produces minecraft and multiplayer game
videos the oven sures was to be an
open-world sandbox crafting and building
game inspired by minecraft it featured
characters designed by the Yogscast
members in May 2012 the yobs ventures
Kickstarter ended with a total of five
hundred and sixty seven thousand dollars
more than double the $250,000 goal in an
email to its Kickstarter backers
Yogscast explained that the collapse of
the project resulted from the team's
lack of experience and limited funds
Louis brinley the co-founder of yogscast
said the project was proving too
ambitious and difficult for them to
complete with their six-man team
brindley explained although we're under
no obligation to do anything and said
we're going to do our best to make this
right and make you really glad you back
project Yogscast is providing backers
with a code for the game tug now on
steam early access and they have
provided tug developer nerd Kingdom with
all the assets from yog casts canceled
game to make the best use of winter cool
work Daniel Dwyer will be covering more
of the failure and fallout of yogs
denture on this week's episode of the
point so be sure to tune in to gamespot
com
you